equally is one type of morphogenetic
movement that usually occurs during the
embryonic development it involves
spreading of a layer as a unit on top of
another layer encapsulating the entire
layer so during
embryogenesis or gastrulation API bully
is one category of molecular movement
among the others during epiboli this
yellow layer shown here gradually
spreads on top of this Green Layer and
encapsulate the entire Green Layer and
this is what happens during epiboli so
one should understand how these yellow
layer can encapsulate a people can occur
via cellular processes like cell
division
cell shape changes and may be splitting
of layers or a combination of all of
these
example of epipoli includes ectoderm
formation in the amphibians
watch full video to know more